[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
sexualité des adolescents la sexualité
ne se porte pas bien d'après les
sondages d'opinion en témoigne les
problèmes qui s'en rapportent et qui
crée un véritable malaise au point où
certains observateurs parlent de
sexualité toxique on pourrait presque
dire qu'il y a un désamour pour les
rapports sexuels au sein des jeunes
générations d'après les sondages portant
sur l'année 2022 43 % des jeunes âgés de
15 à 24 ans n'auraient pas eu de rapport
sexuel dans dans les 12 derniers mois en
comparaison les aînés en couple selon le
même sondage Haris interactive de
juillet 2023 montre que la révolution
pardonnez-moi la révolution Mitou n'a
pas vraiment changé les habitudes
sexuelles avec des hommes plus
entreprenants et des femmes moins
satisfaites même si l'on observe une
hétérogénéité des pratique sexuelles et
de nouveaux modes de jouissance quelles
sont les raisons de ce désamour
pour ce qui constitue quoi qu'on pense
un penchant pour la vie et d'accuser
alors pmel les abus de la société de
consommation où tout passe dans le
commerce de la consommation
pornographique au rêve la confusion
entretenue autour de l'orientation
sexuelle quand elle est dogmatiquement
genrée par la radicalisation des
minorités agissantes et une industrie
numérique des sexes ajoute au malaise le
besoin de procréation reproduction rendu
insignifiant j'emprunte ce terme à Milan
Kunda face au triomphe d'un espèce de
narcissisme
hérotomaniaque qui se prend pour le
nombril de la modernité on peut aussi
incriminer dans ce malaise les
déliaisons sociales la déchéance du
mariage les viols les féminicides bref
un ressentiment général à l'égard de
l'amour et du sexe que nous allons
interroger avec mes invités que je vous
présente Alain Vanier vous êtes
psychiatre psychanalyste et professeur
émérite des Universités Bruno falissard
vous êtes
pédopsychiatre membre de l'Acad de
l'Académie nationale de médecine et
également universitaire Julia Sissa que
nous avons en
visioonférence vous êtes professeur
d'université à l'université de Los
Angeles vous êtes également historienne
et philosophe Christine vadat vous êtes
pardonnez-moi Christine Vada vous êtes
gynécologue et
[Musique]
obstétricienne vous venez de voir la
citation de Simon veale la baisse
d'activité sexuelle chez les nouvelles
générations vous inquiète-elle et à quoi
la attbuez-vous est-ce une altération de
l'altérité en écho à ce que vient de
vous venez de voir avec la citation de
Simon veille Alain Vanier
alors c'est sûr qu'il y a alors qu'il y
a des modifications de de la vie
sexuelle est-ce qu'on est certain qu'il
y a une baisse de l'activité sexuelle
parce que je ne sais pas si des études
comme ça si on peut comparer avec des
études antérieures ce qui est sûr c'est
que la sexualité a pris une place
considérable dans le discours social
c'est vrai à tout point de vue
euh mais est-ce que les pratiques
elles-mêmes ont beaucoup évolué je
question que je me pose voilà et vous
Bruno fissa mettez en cause ces
sondage non après est-ce que plus c'est
mieux pour la sexualité moi je sais pas
fa moi je Seris d'ailleurs plus
intéressé pour savoir si les adolescents
ou les jeunes adultes sont heureux de
leur sexualité quand bien même elle ne
serait pas fréquente peut-être que c'est
nous qui avons consumérisé la sexualité
avec le plus c'est mieux d'ailleurs
comptez même compter un nombre de
rapports sexuels par mois est-ce que
c'est pertinent est-ce que à finalement
faire l'amour une bonne fois dans un
mois en étant complètement réalisé dans
sexual dans sa sexualité c'est pas mieux
donc euh après là je vous rejoins dans
votre introduction
euh je vois beaucoup de jeune avec de
l'écho-anxiété de l'écholère du fait que
la terre est surpeuplée et cetera et que
se reproduit
ben c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
et que quand même la sexualité est en
rapport avec la reproduction et
peut-être qu'il y a une mise à l'écart
de la sexualité de ce côté-là mais enfin
moi ça ne m'inquiète pas plus que ça
écoutez on va demander à Julien Sissa si
c'est pareil aux États-Unis est-ce que
vous diriez que les jeunes ont moins de
relations sexuelles de rapport sexuel
aux
États-Unis et
bien cette discussion a été lancé en
2018 justement aux
États-Unis par Kate Julian dans un
article autour duquel après s'est créé
beaucoup beaucoup de
curiosité dans The Atlantic et elle a
lancé cette idée de la
sex recession et donc j'ai regardé un
petit peu j'ai vu aussi qu'en Italie et
en Europe ailleurs qu'en France il y a
des statistiques qui convergent vers
cette espèce de diminution du fer
n'est-ce pas et de la fréquence alors
Kate Julian c'est une esséiste et elle
avait essayé de réfléchir à des
justement à des données à des
statistiques et elle avait
identifié quelques points qui est qui
semblait s'imposer des raisons qui
semblaient s'imposer bah la pornographie
F on va rentrer dans le détail mais
d'accord sur le mais oui ré sur la
consommation si je puux dire oui la
réponse est oui il y a une espèce de
convergence statistique sur sur oui
absolument alors on va voir le point de
vue français avec Christine Vada vous
confirme que cette chose là Christine
Vada non moi d'abord c'est un peu biaisé
puisque je vois des adolescentes par mon
par mon activité de
gynécoobstcétricienne et ces
adolescentes que je vois ils ne
m'apparaît pas en 35 ans d'exercice
qu'il y a une baisse de la fréquence des
rapports sexuels par contre ce qui me
marque c'est une augmentation d'un
ressenti de crainte de la part de ces
adolescents sur comment vivre leur
sexualité sur le problème du
consentement sur la peur euh consécutive
de la pornographie on en a parlé mais
aussi de se trouvé sur des sur des
réseaux sociaux parce qu'elles ont eu
des actes sexuels avec des des garçons
donc il y a une perte de confiance qui
me paraît beaucoup plus importante mais
sur la diminution de la fréquence je ne
le note pas du tout dans mon exercice en
somme vous met vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ce sondage peut-être que ce sondage
est erroné mais en tout cas je voudrais
quand même vous faire préciser cette
question l'orientation sexuelle
aujourd'hui reste biologique stable
entre hommes et femmes pour la majorité
de la population alors sociologiquement
c'est autre chose on a une sexualité
polymorphe il y a les théories du genre
il y a l'abstinence la sexualité
l'hétérosexualité
l'homosexualité à votre avis et ça va
préciser votre propos est-ce qu'on ne
cherche pas à promouvoir une alternative
à la
sexualité à travers la
dégénitalisation des rapports sexuels
autrement dit des rapports sexuels sans
pénétration sans accouplement et
cetera oui Bruno falissard oui mais
d'abord je crois que c'est propre à
l'être humain de séparer ce qui est de
la libito de du génital et du sexuel
notre sexualité ça n'est pas que du
génital d'ailleurs ça me rasser sur la
bouche c'est pas génital pourtant ça
fait partie de la sexualité et il y a de
la créativité chez les humains pour
faire exploser le sexuel en tout un tas
de
et pour le meilleur d'ailleurs en
général donc moi c'est c'est pas une
inquiétude c'est c'est une
transformation sociale qui est comme
elle est oui ça vous inquiète Alain
Vanier je crois que ce qui ce qui change
aussi je tout à fait dans le sens de de
ce que dit
Bruno ce qui change beaucoup aussi c'est
la c'est l'espèce de
transparence de des pratiques et de la
vie les vieexuelle on avait une vision
moins moins évidente de tout ce qui se
passait dans le secret de la vie
sexuelle qui aujourd'hui est quand
même
exposé spectacularisé et cetera donc il
me semble qu'il y a là une modification
tout à fait importante de plus je je
crois qu'il y a un élément peut-être
qu'il faudrait ajouter c'est aussi
une une pente à l'isolement une pente à
la solitude dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
à tel point que je crois qu'il y a même
dans des dans certains pays un ministère
ou un secrétaire état à la solitude et
qui me paraît une question très très
très très importante alors docteur
Christine Vada vous qui êtes gynécologue
est-ce que
cette
dégénétalisation de la sexualité vos
patientes en parlent en quelque sorte
est-ce qu'ell cherch une sexualité
alternative à une sexualité qui serait
disons uniquement basée sur les rapports
ine Vada alors oui j'ai j'ai j'ai quand
même sans vouloir caricaturer j'ai une
grande majorité de patientes qui n'ont
rien changé dans leurs habitudes avec la
crainte dont je vous parlais qui bloque
quand même
les aller vers l'autre il y il y a la
problématique de la confiance et du
consentement qui pose problèmes dans les
relations entre les adolescents en tout
cas c'est ce que me relatent les les
patientses ensuite il y a pas de
recherche de différence et après j'ai
une minorité de patientes qui vont se
dire non binaire qui vont remettre en
question leur genre et on pourra parler
de ces demandes de parcours de
transition et dans celles qui ne veulent
absolument pas d'une d'un genre binaire
il va y avoir effectivement une absence
totale de désir sexuel de de de
d'érotisation de la relation à deux et
des comportements qui seront différents
mais ça reste une minorité est-ce que
c'est différent pour les femmes que vous
avez comme patientes qui ont 20 ans et
celles qui ont 50 ans et pareil pour les
hommes vous êtes une écologue donc je
vois pas d'homme donc je je vais parler
de des femmes c'est pas du tout pareil
que pour pour les patients de 20 et de
50 ans mais mes patients de an que j'ai
vu quand elles avaient 20 ans puisque ça
fait plus de 30 ans que je suis
installée elles elles avaient la même la
même la même préoccupation il y avait
simplement une expression moins grande
je rejoins des intervenants tout à
l'heure effectivement il y a une
libéralisation de la parole c'est-à-dire
que peut-être que certaines patientes
qui
euh n'ont pas de relation sexuelle à 50
ans qui n' non jamais eu qui euh à 20
ans ne s'affirmit pas comme étant euh
non dans un modèle binaire ou refusant
toute forme de
sexualité donc je retrouve des des
patients qui n'ont peut-être pas exprimé
ce que maintenant à 20 ans elles pourrai
exprimer ou que pour celles qui ont 20
ans euh elles peuvent exprimer
facilement je sais pas si je suis claire
dans mes explications mais j'ai pas
comis Julia je vais demander l'avis de
Julia Sissa à ce niveau vous savez qu'on
dit traditionnellement en France que
tout ce qui concerne la moderne un ité à
la fois dans ses progrès comme dans sa
perversité ça nous vient des États-Unis
est-ce que finalement cette
dégénitalisation du sexe ça vient des
États-Unis bah euh si je reprends le fil
justement de de cette enquête qui a
enclenché la conversation dans laquelle
nous sommes engagés
aujourd'hui ce qui émergeit justement de
ces données c'était euh la masturbation
c'est-à-dire le
l'auto-érotisme comme une forme de
sexualité de sensualité et je pense que
la sensualité c'est bien euh connecté à
la présence donc massive et tellement
facile tellement accessible des images
pornographiques euh 2èe point ce qui
vient des États-Unis semble être que il
y a moins de relations stables euh parmi
les jeunes parmi les adolescents et donc
moins de euh comment dire de fréquence
dans la sensualité et dans la sexualité
et puis les pratiques justement des
rendez-vous euh sur tinder et et autres
sites où il y a beaucoup de euh hooking
up beaucoup de euh de rencontres mais
pas nécessairement de rendez-vous et de
pratiques sexuelles qui suivent et puis
et ça concerne apparemment les jeunes
femmes et je trouvais ça très
intéressant c'est que justement
apparemment je dis apparemment parce que
je ne suis pas la chercheuse qui a
travaillé n'est-ce pas sur ces données
et la pornographie favorise une espèce
de d'artaimé n'est-ce pas de de
technique de la de du rapport sexuel de
la posture du fer du fer sexuel on vous
a entendu pour les femmes qui est
douloureuse pour les on vous a entendu
vous voulez intervenir madame Vada et
euhou et je termine l'autre point qui
est très important je pense et et ça
recoupe ce que je viens d'entendre
justement d'un point de vue de pratique
gynécologique le fait que les jeunes les
femmes euh mais pas nécessairement
seulement les femmes sont moins à l'aise
dans leur corps h et ça c'est c'est tout
ça interroge céit c'est-à-dire ce son on
vous on vous a
entendu on vous a entendu Juli Sissa je
voudrais avoir l'avis sur ce point du
docteur
Vada je je voulais dire que pour les 14
20 ans dans mon expérience je n'ai
absolument pas moi la notion de de
tinder et cetera les rencontres se font
comme autrefois au lycée dans le groupe
de des élèves
de ou dans le le les copains du frère et
cetera et et je m'appuie pour dire ça
sur une enquête de Isabelle claire qui a
été publié en mars
2023 qui est une sociologue he Isabelle
claire elle a publié ça donc c'est très
récent c'est une enquête qu'elle a mené
sur 20 ans dans des groupes
totalement sociaux différents
de et c'est une étude française et qui
démontre contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait entendre sur les les ce que les
chiffres précédents et cetera que
vraiment le couple hétérosexuel reste
l'horizon rêvé des adolescents c'est
vraiment le le le ce vers quoi tendent
les adolescents pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux c'est le modèle au cœur des
préoccupations c'est vraiment être en
couple dans une relation hétérosexuel et
c'est après que d'autres d'autres formes
de de modèle et de de de désir même
d'une de sexualité différente
apparaissent mais le démarrage 14 20 ans
c'est une une une un modèle très
hétérosexuel et très correspondant aux
critères que l'on connaît depuis des
années alors Philippe brenau vous êtes
psychiatre anthropologue sexologue vous
venez de nous rejoindre dans cette
discussion à laquelle vous allez
participer euh le docteur vada a cité
une étude d'Isabelle Clerc en disant que
chez les adolescents le modèle
hétérosexuel restait un modèle mais dans
cette étude elle parle également je
parle d'Isabelle clerire des différentes
formes de faire l'amour selon l'espace
social le lieu de résidence la religion
est-ce que c'est évident Bruno fallissar
est-ce que vous pouvez dire quelques
mots là-dessus bah oui bien sûr
l'exercice de la sexualité est
culturellement dépendant et ça depuis
l'histoire soir des temps moi j'imagine
euh oui alors et comme en ce moment en
plus les représentations culturelles
changent à toute vitesse parce que nous
sommes exposés à des différences en
permanence via les réseaux sociaux via
l'Internet effectivement les jeunes sont
confrontés à une multitude de plaisir un
vertige de l'infini sexuel et dans
lequel il faut piocher éventuellement
changeant le genre et cetera et cetera
et donc il y a sûrement un temps
d'adaptation à avoir et c'est vrai que
du coup on peut ressentir un certain
malaise auprès des adolescentses
tellement ça change vite tellement il y
a de le mal de l'infini comme disaient
les sociologues hein mais étant un un
optimiste invétéré euh j'imagine que
dans quelques années nous arriverons à
digérer tout ça et que finalement on
arrivera à trouver sa place dans sa
sexualité Philippe brenau est-ce que
vous croyez qu'il y a un invariant
sexuel ou un sexuel qui se meut
complètement qui se transforme P en PER
en permanence des invariants sexuelles
il en a très peu euh mais pour dire une
chose tiens je rappellerai que la
sexualité humaine
elle est comportementalement apprise
c'està dire tout est appris et ça on le
dit pas suffisamment et ça va être
appris au fil des expériences
successives elle est comportementalement
apprise et elle est socialement
construite c'estàdire que ça va être
construit en fonction des images que
l'on voit il est évident qu'un enfant
aujourd'hui dans notre société comme
vous venez de le dire qui qui bouge à
chaque moment enfin c'est pas les mêmes
en 2000 en 2010 en 2015 là avec les
hashtags ça a tout changé aujourd'hui
que je sais pas dans un pays par exemple
très restrictif en Iran un enfant n'a
pas les mêmes repères du tout il aura sa
sexualité qui sera pas la même la grande
difficulté c'est que en même temps que
ces
repères évoluent et aujourd'hui on va y
revenir parce que c'est c'est ça qui qui
pose problème propère dans d'orientation
et d'identité et bien en même temps que
ces repères évoluent il faut pas oublier
que la sexualité est en train de se
construire c'est-à-dire que plus on
cumule des des expériences c'est en
fonction des expériences que l'on a
qu'on va avoir la sexualité qui sera la
nôtre donc toutes les sexualités sont
personnelles alors ici à ce plateau de
LCP nous avons eu un grand économiste
Daniel Cohen qui est aujourd'hui décéd
et qui expliquait
magistralement que les relations
sociales étaient ébréchées pour ne pas
dire plus par le numérique j'aimerais
avoir l' vie de Julia Sissa sur ce point
est-ce que vous pensez que le numérique
porte atteinte à la sensualité à la la
sexualité à l'amour et cetera et essayer
de parler sans comment dire sans tabou
parce parce que dès qu'on parle de de
ça euh sans tabout euh bah ni totem ni
tabou c'est c'est-à-dire que
euh je n'ai pas peur du numérique je le
fréquente pas
nécessairement mais je ça ne me fait pas
peur je pense que la la rus de la raison
fait que on trouve des manières toujours
plus fines plus plus malines plus plus
intelligente de faire avec les
technologies qui sont à notre
disposition donc je ne sais pas si c'est
ça le S tabou oui
[Musique]
euh je parlais avec des amis euh qui
disaient euh des amis qui certain un
couple d'hommes mariés qui s'adorent et
qui disaent
euh quand nous parlons à des gens plus
jeunes et et nous racontons comment nous
nous sommes rencontrés nous nous sommes
som rencontré à Rome dans un café ils
sont tout à fait surpris parce que euh
justement les pratiques maintenant de la
rencontre se sont tellement transférés
sur internet alors est-ce qu'il faut
regretter ça est-ce qu'il faut dire
qu'on a perdu ce qu'on appelle le
romantisme qu'on a perdu cette dimension
de l'art d'aimer et de la civilité
érotique euh de de la séduction
intéressante moi je dis pas
nécessairement pas nécessairement
peut-être que euh il y a dans dans dans
ces manières de faire une temporalité
différente de la séduction une façon
d'attendre euh de cultiver précisément
la recherche la quête du désir de
l'Autre qui n'est pas plus mal pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faudrait se précipiter au
lit tout de suite moi je si vous voulez
je suis une féministe de la 2e vague
j'ai vécu les années 70 sous les pavés
la plage et la plage j'était une plage
où on faisait surtout l'amour n'est-ce
pas mais est-ce que c'était bien est-ce
que cette espèce de
de de glissement évident de la
conversation à la à l'acte sexuel était
agréable à chaque fois je ne sais pas je
ne suis pas sûr oui et donc peut-être
que c'est une bonne nouvelle que que les
jeunes prendent le temps prent prenre le
temps peut-être dans ce dans
ce alors Alain Vanier dans votre
consultation eu égard au covid et égard
au numérique est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut faire l'amour avec un
ordinateur
ah je dans ma consultation c'est sûr que
c'est ce que euh parense que ça prolonge
ce quiit ce qu'on se disait tout à
l'heure c'est sûr que la
euh les pratique solitaire devant la
pornographie ou devant l'ordinateur ou
même avec un autre à travers
l'ordinateur se sont beaucoup développés
il y a il y a il faut quand même dire
que la ce que nous vivons c'est une
sorte de 3ème révolution industrielle
c'est la révolution numérique elle
changera elle aura des effets sur le
lien social inévitablement maintenant
qui a une
sexualité
[Musique]
normal comment dire orthodoxe et cetera
ça je pense que c'est un c'est une
fantaisie qui a appartenu aux ordres
religieux et cetera diffèire la sex
humaine comme disait Freud elle est
fondamentalement dénaturée hein donc
elle n'a pas d'orientation spécifique
qui a une fin spécifique qui rait de soi
et pour vous Philippe brenaud
l'influence du numérique sur
l'influence du numérique est évidente
puisque on dirait le numérique est
surtout internet ça date en gros des
années 2000 avant il y a très peu ça
existe un petit peu depuis tout a été
transformé et ce queon vient d'évoquer
les deux interventions de d' Vanier de
Madame Julia dont j'ai pas le nom
complet
euh marque
bien la dimension du temps qu'il
faudrait avoir moi je crois qu'on est
dans des sociétés aujourd'hui où il n'y
a il y a pas tellement de recul
d'ailleurs on le voit avec la W culture
il faudrait il faut réagir dans
l'émotion dans l'immédiateté
orors on va se on va reculer même de 30
40 ans en arrière je crois que la
société laissait plus de temps au début
de la sexualité et qui est peut-être un
temps de la maturation de la maturation
psychologique relationnelle est-ce que
les gamins qui sont confrontés très vite
à un sexe qu'il faut assumer avec des
impératifs impératif orgasmique tout ce
qu'on veut il comprennent rien est-ce
qu'ils sont matures au niveau de la
relation il vaudrait mieux être mature
au niveau de la relation et de soi-même
pour moi j'ai l'impression que les soci
avec le numérique s accéléré et ça c'est
un handicap mais on est obligé de faire
[Musique]
avec alors d'après le sondage Haris
interactive sur lequel vous n'êtes pas
d'accord pour la plupart en considérant
qu'il avait moins de relations sexuelles
dans les jeunes générations il y a
également dans ce même
sondage une analyse des effets de la
Révolution Mitou
et ces effets se font attendre autrement
dit dans le domaine des relations
sexuelles Mitou n'a pas changé
grandchose qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
docteur
Vada alors oui ça rejoint tout ce qui ce
que je lis et toutes les les études là
je suis tout à fait d'accord là-dessus
il y a pas de modification significative
dans le comportement alors là j'ai
j'étend mes propos à mes patientes
au-delà de de 20 ans hein qui ne sont
pas que les adolescents on retrouve les
ST les stéréotypes que l'on connaissait
et je voudrais juste revenir même si
c'est pas le propos sur des chiffres qui
me paraissent extrêmement inquiétants
qui sont ceux de de de des des 70 % de
garçons qui sont allés sur des sites
pornographiques et 40 % des filles et ça
pour rebondir avec ce qui a été dit par
le dernier intervenant je je pense que
c'est très très important parce que
effectivement il y a pas la maturité ça
je le ressens dans mes consultations
donc je m'éloigne un peu de votre
question je m'en excuse mais je voulais
bien insister là-dessus et je pense que
c'est ce qui fait l'appréhension
également dans mes jeunes patientes
entre au-delà de 14 ans sur ces premiè
relations sexuelles il y a une espèce de
de de modèle qui leur a été imposé de
modèles qui correspond pas et qui ne
fonctionne pas avec l'amour avec les
sentiments qui est imposé par ses images
pornographiques et et ça je pense que
c'est vraiment le problème essentiel et
toujours pour revenir sur la sociologue
que dont j'aime beaucoup les les
l'étude je je pense
que ça va en plus être différent en
fonction de le de de la relation
qu'elles ont avec leurs parents
c'est-à-dire que dans des familles
structurantes qui tiennent la route ces
images pornographiques n'auront pas le
même retentissement négatif donc
excusez-moi d'être reparti un peu en
arrière sur Mitou j'ai juste à dire qu'
il n'y a pas de modification pour moi
euh dans les habitudes sexuelles de mes
patientes en tout cas euh depuis la
Révolution Mitou bon alors Bruno
fallissard moi j'entends ce que dis ce
que disent des médecin gynécologue
psychiatre et cetera on a le sentiment
qu'il y a un décalage
entre les expériences vécues telles
qu'elles sont ressenties et les études
qui viennent schématiser la chose
autrement dit la sexualité c'est quelque
chose freud disait déjà que c'était
difficile mais c'est difficile d'en
parler
pour disons de d'exprimer ça avec une
transparence du langage ben d'abord
est-ce que nous nous sommes transparents
par rapport à notre propre sexualité
j'en suis pas sûr et donc est-ce qu'on
est capable d'en parler de façon
complètement objective j'en suis pas sûr
non plus moi je crois que d'ailleurs ça
a été dit tout à l'heure la vraie
question de tout c'est la question du
consentement et là avec les jeunes
avecquels je suis la question du
consentement est vraiment une question
compliquée mais d'ailleurs c'est une
question philosophiquement compliquée
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que de
consentir à quelque chose qui est le jeu
qui consent puisque quelque part j'ani
envie mais j'en ai pas envie quelque
part l'autre a envie de moi son désir
provoque mon propre désir mais est-ce
que c'est mon désir à moi alors que
c'est le ciel mais les femmes disent les
femmes disent céder n'est pas consentir
et ben oui bien sûr mais mais tout ça
est terriblement compliqué
et je pense que c'est très bien
aujourd'hui de poser la question du
consentement c'est vraiment un progrès
manifeste mais ne pas dire en même temps
que cette question est insoluble
philosophiquement et ben je pense que
c'est dramatique chacun doit se poser à
l'intérieur de soi-même à l'intérieur du
couple finalement quand tu me demandes
ça quand je fais ça est-ce que je
consent parlons-en mais il y a pas de
vérité là-dedans oui alors sur Mitou
Alain Vanier que le fait que ça ça n'it
pas
changé dans l'étude on dit que les
femmes restent plutôt soumises à la
puissance machiste est-ce que c'est
alors c'est intéressant de voir que les
évolutions sociologiques ne se
traduisent pas en quelque sorte sur les
pratiques elles-mêmes alors je je crois
qu'il y a deux choses déjà je rejoins ce
que dit ce que dit Bruno très justement
c'est très compliqué le la question du
consentement parce que je donne à
l'autre je je pense combien de patientes
m'ont expliqué que leors le rythme de
leur désirs leur envie n'était pas tout
du tout le même que celui de leur
compagnon par exemple ou ou de leur
compagne même dans des cas de couple
homosexuel mais qu'en même temps par
moment bah pour pas avoir d'histoire ou
pour que le la relation soit bonne et
ben on cède alors dans ce cas-là est-ce
que c'est un consentement est-ce que
c'est un don qu'on fait à l'autre c'est
très compliqué sur le sur les effets De
Mitou il me semble qu' il va falloir ce
genre de chose a des effets mais à mon
avis euh il faut du temps entre le
moment où il y a
ce comment dire cette venue à jour cette
exposition ENF de ces de toutes
ces complications dans les relations
homm-femme il me semble que là il faut
plus d'une génération ou plus de
quelques années pour pouvoir euh pouvoir
en mesurer les effets dans la vie
subjective parce que ce qui est très
compliqué c'est que toutes ces images
tout ce qui sort dans les discours tout
ce qui apparaît sont vécu aussi comme
des impératifs comme des modèles en
particulier dans les dans la culture du
dans laquelle nous sommes donc il faut
beaucoup de temps pour pour que tout ça
prenne prenne place dans les dans les
liens sociaux sans compter qu'à mon avis
on est dans une dans un moment social où
il y a une sorte véritablement
d'émiettement donc ce qui va conduire ou
organiser certains groupes n'est pas ce
qui conduira d'autres groupes alors
juliaen Sissa vous
m'entendez aux
États-Unis encore une fois on revient
sur les États-Unis
euh on considère qu'un
regard
est suscitant un désir sexuel est déjà
prédateur est-ce que vous pensez que
cette chose- là c'est pas ce qui a
affaibli le mouvement féministe et quand
on prend la France vous avez vu la
citation de Florence Foresti mais de
grandes voix que ce soit Catherine
denuve que ce soit Sylvi nagazenski que
ce soit madame ellisabeth Badinter ont
considéré que cet excès là à nuit à la
Révolution
Mitou vaste question pluriel
euh j'ai j'ai envie de de commencer en
disant euh que euh c'est une question de
situation c'est-à-dire que Mitou
euh a ciblé dans le témoignage de ces
femmes qui disent moi aussi n'est-ce pas
ass ciblé de relations
euh qui deviennent érotique au mauvais
moment et euh quand ce n'est pas
vraiment la raison pourquoi une femme
s'engage dans une relation dans une
conversation avec un homme donc l'idée
c'était c'est lié à une espèce d'erreur
de encore une fois de situation je suis
là dans un entretien professionnel je
suis là dans un coloque je je suis là
dans une
relation qui est une relation de
subordination par rapport à vous vous
estimez vous estimez que si on dit de
vous vous êtes belle c'est une relation
de subordination non je dis pas ça je
dis justement que tout dépend du quand
et du où et du du moment situationnel
dans lequel on me dit je suis belle
c'est-à-dire que je peux même être
offenscé si on me dit pas que je suis
belle dans une situation où il y a une
intimité même ironique
esthétique et et érotique avec quelqu'un
et tout le
monde a a ce désir d'être désiré
n'est-ce pas mais c'est le moment qui
compte et le mouvement Mutou a mis en
évidence justement cette espèce de de
ralbol des femmes d'être traité de sur
le dans le registre érotique au moment
où n'en nont pas envie Jul est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas une contradiction entre ce que
vous dites d'un côté vous dites que on
peut dire certaines choses dans une
intimité et d'un autre côté accepter la
médiatisation complète de la sexualité
en considérant qu'elle doit suivre la
modernité euh
oui je dis ça dans le sens que si la
modernité est euh l'émancipation des
femmes
et l'accès l'ADM Miss des femmes au
droit cité comme dirait condorsé ou le
la la présence des femmes dans des
situations professionnelles des
interactions professionnelles où vous
êtes là en tant que en tant que euh prof
journaliste
ouvrière secrétaire
ou même
chef vous êtes là en tant que po femme
politique et bien ce n'est pas le moment
ce n'est pas euh la situation dans
laquelle vous acceptez avec plaisir un
compliment sur votre coiffure ou en
compliment sur vos seins c'est justement
essayez de terminer votre propos
modernité oui c'est justement si par
modernité on entend la présence des
femmes dans l'espace social et dans
l'espace du pouvoir alors effectivement
il faut comportementaliser il faut
séparer donc le même compliment dont on
n pas envie en tant que femme dans une
situation professionnelle ce même
compliment et bien on en est très
heureuse au lit ou euh dans un dîner un
tête à-tête puisque le romantisme
revient aussi euh dans merci euh
Philippe brenaud sur ce point je crois
que vous voulez intervenir ou à la fois
je suis d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire Julia si si ça si pardon si ça si
ça je suis désolé Julia euh
les que la sexualité des jeunes est
changé depuis pas fondamentalement mais
que ça ait transformé la société que ça
va transformer les consciences mais
formidable formidablement ce que nous
essayons de faire tous les gens qui
s'occupent de sexualité que soit quel
qu'il soit depuis 40 ans on n'arrivait
pas à le faire à faire comprendre je me
souviens avoir écrit en 2008 un livre
qui s'appelait les violences ordinaires
des hommes envers les femmes je la
plupart des gens me disaient mais tu
crois pas que c'est
l'inverse maintenant je veux dire les
hashtags vont avoir permis une prise de
conscience le hashtag inceste fait
permet de de comprendre des choses que
nous n'arrivions pas à dire alors après
dernière un petit une petite pondération
par rapport à des choses qui ont pu être
dites avant
euh le problème des études et je ne sais
pas celle dont vous parliez qu'elle
Estelle moi je crois qu'il y en a pas
très pas beaucoup d'études sur la
sexualité il y a beaucoup de sondages
fait par des journaux il y a des études
il y en a qui sont idéologiques et
notamment parce qu'il y a trois en
France il y a trois études essayz deêtre
pas trop long parce qu'il nous reste peu
de temps d'émissionac mais il y a trois
études dans le derniè c'est c'est celle
de de Michel bouson et et de Natalie
bajos et de Nathalie Bajos il va y en
avoir une autre comme ça mais elle ne
montre pas à tout un tas de choses qui
sont soutenues souvent par des assosces
et qu'on va soutenir nous-même pour
arriver à arrêter la discrimination mais
on voit des pourcentages hallucinants
dans des travaux qui ne sont pas des
études scientifiques donc il faut être
prudent et notamment dernier point c'est
sur la baisse de la sexualité des jeunes
il y a une espèce de métaanalyse qui a
été faite il y a 3 ou 4 ans aux
États-Unis je me demande même si elle a
pas été téléguidée par des des milieux
euh conservateurs oui mais là là il
s'agit pas des États-Unis c'est une
étude française enfin c'est un sondage
français mais mais nous on ne voit pas
ça dans les gens que nous voyons c'est
ça alors Christine Vada vous vouliez
intervenir mais je je voulais rebondir
sur ce que disait euh madame Sissa et
j'avais je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec elle tout dépend du contexte
effectivement qu'on aime que l'on nous
dise que on est belle mais si mais ça ne
me viendrait pas à l'idée dans une
réunion de vous dire vous êtes beau oh
que vous vous êtes beau vous êtes
magnifique aujourd'hui vous voyez donc
je pense non mais j'ai mais non mais en
en l'occurrence ça vous est jamais
arrivé or à nous ça nous est arrivé de
nous retrouver dans des situations où on
était là où on avait le sentiment d'être
totalement dans une égalité parfaite
avec les autres intervenants avec les
autres participants et ça ça revient
tout le temps moi j'ai des patientes qui
sont dans des conseils d'administration
qui me disent que c'est systématique
elle qu'Al disait comme ça une un pseudo
compliment qui est totalement déplacé et
qu'elle le viv comme totalement déplacé
alors qu'elles sont absolument ravies
d'être désiré dès qu'elles sont elles
ont terminé leur leur réunion donc il
faut je pense que là-dessus euh il y a
Mitou est sûrement pas mal et je ne
rejoins pas ce que vous avez celle que
vous avez cité qui ont crié à la
catastrophe voilà il y a il faut pas
tomber dans les excès mais c'est vrai
que il y a à remettre du contexte
dans le compliment que l'on fait aux
femmes toutes les les femmes que je vois
acceptent tous les compliments des
hommes à condition qu'il soit fait comme
au moment où c'est l'histoire du
consentement aussi c'est il y a il y a
un moment donné où c'est la place à la
séduction au compliment et cetera et
puis il y a le les moments où ce n'est
pas la place et c'est le discours de
celle qui le prononce ou de des propos
qu'elle tient qui doit être pris en
compte au-delà de son aspect physique
merci Madame alors Alain Vanier une
question qui fâche oui parce j'aimerais
bien que je vous interroge là-dessus
parce que vous avez dirigé bonœil
c'est-à-dire un centre d'adolescents qui
s'occupait de
psychopédagogie en tout cas aider les
adolescents à se réinsérer dans la
société aujourd'hui on laisse vous avez
parlé de solitude mais on voit aussi des
bandes de garçons et des filles et il y
a une séparation est-ce que vous
considérez que des garçons qui n'ont pas
de relation sexuelle ou qui ne vont pas
avec des filles sont plus
violents alors autrement dit c'est c'est
c'est un sujet de délinquence oui oui
non le alors je précise que bonœil est
un c'est un hôpital de jour qui
accueillait des enfants parfois très
jeunes et jusqu'à des adolescents et que
c'était un lieu dit d'antipsychiatrie
c'était comme cela quand quand mon
Manoni l'a fondé je ne l'ai pas dirigé
j'y ai travaillé mais
euh les bandes de garçons ont toujours
existé les bandes de filles c'était
moins fréquent mais le lien avec les
amis et les copines et cetera c'était
très important et il y avait
effectivement enfin il y avait une
ségrégation sexuelle je rappelle quand
même
que je suis certainement l'un des plus
âgés ici les écoles n'étaient pas mixtes
il y a quand même pas si longtemps que
ça il y a une cinquantaine d'années il y
av éc oui estce que le féminin est un
facteur de pacification des instincts si
vous voulez c'est-à-dire rester rester
entre homme en quelque sorte et
notamment chez les bande de jeunes
est-ce que ça secrète pas de la
délinquence on dit que le la exité
apporterait plus
d'humanité de toute façon on peut être
d'accord avec une idée que ça
apporterait plus d'humanité mais mais je
ne crois pas que les bandes de garçons
suscitent automatiquement de la
délinquence tout dépend comment
s'organiseent ces bandes leur lieux les
condition sociales c'est elles ont
toujours existé hein je moi qui suis
certainement le plus âgé ici ma jeunesse
Ctait du blouson noir c'était des bandes
de garçons mais il y avait aussi des
bandes de garçons qui allaient jouer au
bowllying qui se retrouvait pour
euh pour faire de la musique et cetera
donc je suis pas convaincu que ce soit
cela qui soit que la ségrégation des
sexes provoque nécessairement plus de
violence non je crois pas Julia ass ça
comment ça se
passe je suis pasant que je ne suis pas
sûr on a parlait tout à l'heure donc
tant que je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
une augmentation de la violence des
jeune elle est plus spectaculaire elle
est mise en avant par les médias mais je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il y a une
augmentation de la violence des jeunes
par rapport à il y a je sais pas un
demi-siècle par exemple oui Julien Sissa
vous pensez que quoi de cette
violence masculine qui pourrait être
tempéré par un humanisme féminin et ben
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien penser
que euh il y a des traits même
construits bien sûr construits
culturellement euh de la manière des
femmes féminines d'être au monde qui
sont euh partageable de manière heureuse
dans le monde c'est-à-dire
euh le le soin le
souci l'empathie tout ça c'est construit
je ne dis pas que c'est naturel mais euh
c'est bon donc ce serait ce serait bien
que on partage un peu tout ça ceci dit
vous posez une question sur laquelle je
peux pas vous répondre en tant
que chercheuse qui ait travailler sur
ces sur les bandes de de gangs de
délinquants mais peut-être une question
qui se pose beaucoup aux États-Unis et
pertinente ici et la discussion sur les
écoles mixtes ou seulement pour fille ou
seulement pour garçons est-ce que euh
une éducation séparée n'est-ce pas euh
où les genres sont séparés et fait du
bien et est-ce que
que justement en enlevant la dimension
de la sexualité entre fille et garçon on
enlève une distraction et les les avis
divergent et à la
fois au sujet du bénéfice que les filles
tiraaient justement de cette situation
il y a pas de garçon mais aussi pour les
garçons l'idée que il y ait une
éducation masculin qui soit vraiment en
un sens consci de ce qu'il faut faire
pour transformer le mal humain en un
gentleman en un sens et donc que que ce
corps vécu au masculin apprenne à bien
se conduire apprenneent à ne pas être
violent ne pas s'imposer à ne
pas perdre le contrôle justement
irrationnellement de son potentiel de
force et
donc a une réflexion sur tout ça merci
Julia Bruno fissard sur ce point là le
féminin le masculin
aujourd'hui dans sa
conjugaison on sait que ça aide à à
moindrir la délinquence non je pense pas
du tout pas du tout je pense pas du tout
je pense que c'est un mythe hein
vraiment le mythe de la prédation sexuel
le mythe de la testostérone la
testostérone est une hormone qui a un
effet mais c'est ement mythologisé aussi
le mythe de de la compétition entre mâle
pour la femelle qui existe dans chez les
mammifères mais qui est du registre du
symbolique essentiellement avec les
humains donc tout ça est beaucoup plus
compliqué après la question de la
séparation des genre au collège c'est
une vraie question
euh franchement moi je je ne vois pas
comment ça pourrait être
pertinent du moins sur le terme je pense
vraiment que les humains sont fait pour
être ensemble et que les humains divers
quelle que soit la diversité ont
vraiment besoin d'être ensemble pour
apprendre à vivre ensemble qu'ils soi
des hommes des femmes des personnes avec
des handicaps ou pas et et voilà et pour
moi c'est vraiment une évidence clinique
alors après peut-être que ça peut aider
à faire passer un pas mais pas plus que
ça bon ben écoutez on arrive au terme de
cette émission je vais vous poser une
question et chacun pourra donner son mot
de conclusion là-dessus en on est dans
une société de consommation société du
spectacle avec toutes ces qualités ou
ces défauts malbouffe drogue alcool et
cetera mais aussi injonction à la
jouissance à la performance au porno au
viol et cetera vous connaissez tout ça
est-ce que vous pensez
que l'accomplissement de
l'intime va continuer à trouver sa place
où finalement on va vers un nersat en
quelque sorte d'amour et de sexualité
alors brièvement chacun son point de vue
Alain Vanier je pense qu'il a quand même
malgré la la surexposition la
transparence euh d'aujourd'hui et qui
est une
transparence parfois mal vécue je pense
que quand même la plupart
des des personnees en tout cas cell que
je reçois finissent par construire un
espace intime
euh à leur manière mais peut-être aussi
avec en assumant plus facilement euh euh
la diversité ou la singularité des
constructions euh qu'à l'époque au fond
il y avait un ordre plus plus
uniformément défini hein voilà Christine
Vada sur ce mot de ponctuation là oui je
je je suis moi aussi une éternelle
optimisme et optimiste et je trouve que
et je pense que on arrive vers des
relations plus égalité
plus il y a qu'à voir des chiffres sur
le l'âge du premier rapport qui
maintenant est le même pour les filles
et les garçons alors c'est c'est un peu
caricatural mais et simpliste mais j'ai
l'impression qu'au contraire on va vers
du du positifs dans les échanges entre
les relations malgré les déviances que
vous avez cité dans votre question
sur la société de consommation et tous
ces ces délire voilà donc je suis très
optimiste sur les relations garçon fille
et sur ses ados en insistant sur le
consentement qui a été repris et je l'en
remercie par Bruno falissa parce que ça
me paraît la question clé de la
sexualité des adolescents
merci Monsieur
bronau moi je Seris enfin optimiste avec
cette marge de de recul vis-à-vis
d'énormément de facteurs qui se sont
passés il y a une révolution du
numérique vous le disiez c'est en 2000
c'était il y a 23 ans euh il y a les
hashtags c'était il y a 5 6 ans
maintenant c'est incroyable qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé comme chose et beaucoup
de choses sont allé très vite quand on
regarde beaucoup d'études notamment sur
les ados ils sont de plus en plus
critiques ils savent très bien même par
rapport au pornoau c'est pas la vraie
sexualité moi je crois que il faut
attendre une bonne dizaine d'années des
choses vont s'aesantir parce que c'est
allé très vite et tant mieux parce que
c'est des changements qu'on narrivait
pas à faire oui Julien sissas vous
pensez qu' l'intime n'est pas en danger
euh non euh parce que je fais confiance
aux jeunes je pense que tout ce dont on
parle c'est un défi c'est un défi à
l'esprit critique c'est un défi à à la
capacité de décider de choisir de faire
des expériences mais ce que je vois
quand je parle à des jeunes qui me sont
proches à qui je pose ces questions
est-ce que vous pensez que vous êtes des
analphabètes pas beaucoup de Julia
essayez d'être i ben je leur fais
confiance je leur fais confiance je
pense qu'il y a de nouvelles éthiques de
l'intime qui émerge et je suis plutôt
curieuse de ce que je devrais apprendre
de ces jees merci merci alors Bruno
fissard sur cette même question mais par
rapport à ce qu'a dit Christine Vada des
relations plus égalitaires je vous
rappelle simplement que Michel Perot qui
est un écr une écrivaine très connue en
France et qui s'intéresse beaucoup à ces
questions de société elle disait qu'il
faut garder le cap de l'universel pour
réaliser
l'égalité est-ce que c'est est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on fait pas passer
l'égalité avant l'universel c'est une
grosse question mais c'est pour avoir
votre avis est-ce
que d'abord dans le domaine de l'
sexualité et de la vie de couple
l'universel je sais pas ce que c'est par
contre ce que je constate c'est que
vivre à deux proche l'un de l'autre et
pendant de nombreuses années c'est une
valeur qui continue à être extrêmement
forte chez les jeunes et ça
m'impressionne tous les jours c'est très
impressionnant de voir comment vouloir
être à côté de quelqu'un lui tenir la
main regarder la télé ensemble ou
Netflix et cetera ben c'est quelque
chose de très fort encore ok bah écoutez
le temps imparti est écoulé me reste à
vous présenter une brève bibliographie
alors un livre de Magalie crosé Calisto
la révolution du nosexe Magalie crosé
caralisto explique par
contre justement ce que ce dont on a
parlé
c'est-à-dire l'affaiblissement des
relations
sexuelles en partie contesté par
vous-même mais en tout cas elle le
montre alors Julia Sissa vous avez
publié le pouvoir des femmes
chez ODIL Jacob bon c'est évident en un
mot en un mot parce qu'on a peu de temps
il se RA Fermi ou il diminue
en non on avance on avance on
avance vous avancez ah oui on avance
nous avançons toutes et tous ensemble le
féminisme est un grand cadeau à
l'humanité de merci de cet optimiste
Bruno fissard vous avez publié soigné la
souffrance psychique des enfants elle
grandit aujourd'hui dans cette société
de consomation il y a des choses qui
vont mieux il y a moins de tentative de
suicide de suicide chez les adolescents
au cours du 20e du 21e siècle par
certains aspects ça va moins bien il y a
plus de déta dépressif et anxieux donc
il y a du bien il y a du moins bien
alors Philippe brenau pourquoi c'est si
compliqué
l'amour donc c'est toujours une question
complexe oui simplement dans Pourquoi
compliquer l'amour à travers beaucoup
d'expériences et plus de choses que l'on
sait il y a des grandes différences
entre les hommes et les femmes qu'on ne
veut pas acceptter parce qu'on voudrait
qu'il a une sorte d'égalité
idéologiquement je veux bien le soutenir
dans la réalité nous devons faire avec
des stéréotypes et si on les reconnaît
je crois qu'on est mieux si on accepte
les différences que si on les dit merci
Alain vanagier vous êtes un biographe de
Lacan vous préparer un livre là
actuellement euh oui un livre sur la
question des relation
précoce des tout petits enfants à partir
de deux expériences celle d'avoir
travaillé pendant tout un temps avec des
mères psychotiques et leurs bébés avec
une variante très très étonnante de ces
relations très précocece et puis avec
mon épouse qui elle a travaillé en
service dans des services de
réimationental voilà Catherine vanagier
on essaye de faire quelque chose
ensemble de de la leçon qu'on a tiré de
ces expériences voilà merci alors il me
reste à vous remercier à remercier Julia
Sissa de Los
Angeles Christine Vada de sa belle
campagne vous êtes où Christine Vada
normandieandé de la belle Normandie
merci messieurs donc d'avoir participé
merci à l'équipe de LCP qui réalise
cette émission et avant de vous quitter
je voudrais vous soumettre cette pensée
de Michel Welbeck il y a la sexualité
des gens qui s'aiment et la sexualité
des gens qui ne s'aiment pas oui
[Musique]
oui